today's topic Carson Kings you know II
don't start with this kind of silly
thing on ESPN's College GameDay he held
up a sign that read Busch light supply
needs replenish it included his venmo
username he made a few hundred dollars
but then he wanted to make it a bigger
deal and said you know what I want to
donate it to a Children's Hospital all
of a sudden you had anheuser-busch right
they they gifted him a one-year supply
of beer they put his name and face on
the can they and venmo both saying that
they would match donations that people
sent in and the guy ended up raising
over 1 million dollars and yesterday the
Des Moines Register publishes a profile
on Carson Kenan in that profile about
King raising seven figures for a
Children's Hospital they also decided to
report on two racist tweets that King
made back in 2012 when he was 16 years
old we're good we're done
mm mm we're this worried already 2012
importantly while writing about the
story that reporter Erin Calvin actually
asking about those tweets which King
told him that the tweets made him sick
and that he was remorseful for them also
telling the register that's not
something that I'm proud of it all after
talking with the register he reportedly
thanked the newspaper for bringing those
tweets to his attention but actually
before that article was published King
reached out to a local TV station to
defend himself saying in a statement
that those posts quoted and referenced
the show tosh point-o while reading a
statement to reporters he apologized I
am embarrassed and stunned to reflect on
what I thought was funny when I was a 16
year old kid and I want to sincerely
apologize I really hate those canned I'm
sorry's and I recognize you just trying
to do the right thing and get ahead of
it and I respect that but people going
on apology tours because somebody called
them out I really hate it because it
gives credence to these losers who get
online and there's a song he did this
when he was 14 and he should have Paul
calm down if I [ __ ] her because of one
of them one of the means that I posted
or a tweet that I did this is gonna be
my apologies
I [ __ ] up thank you this will be my
apology
you suck my dick [ __ ] anheuser-busch
cutting ties with King saying yes
they'll still do the men whether they'll
have no further association with him and
that's because Kings Post quote do not
align with our values as a brand or as a
company and certainly people asking why
publish this information when King just
a normal person raising money for others
which the Des Moines Register respondent
is doing a statement saying at the
papers executive editors at several
editors had a discussion on whether or
not to publish them saying the jokes
were highly inappropriate and where
public posts shouldn't that be
acknowledged to all the people who had
donated money to King's calls or were
planning to do so no no what does the
posts have to do with money going to
each Children's Hospital so probably
same thing because he said something
like back then when he was 16 I'm not
gonna help those kids that's just logic
I would understand if maybe he was like
a sex offender okay and when he was 18
to 19 and now he's donating to
Children's Hospital there's a
correlation between when you were an
adolescent and you keep a kid kid what's
crazy to me is that you were a bunch of
grown men who sat around a table and
judge this person and I'm sure your
closets aren't clear at all that's a
problem that I have with this because no
matter what you do no matter what you do
you cannot have a chance of redemption
everybody did some bad [ __ ] everybody
and if that is discovered I'm gonna be
canceled I'm gonna be people look at me
I shouldn't be out there it should be
out there so if I cannot read em myself
from something I did when I was 16
why should even I strive to do something
good I would probably push back on that
with you
go ahead by saying this is just like a
minority of people saying this too I
think most people would give you that
chance of redemption well I'm not saying
no but you might use on your money you
might move on yeah yeah on your theme
that you're doing with the editor then
concluding the statement by saying
reasonable people can look at the same
set of facts and disagree on what merits
public
but rest assured such decisions are not
made lightly and are rooted in what we
perceive is the public good well it
should appear as a part of the internet
was like okay sounds great let's flip it
as we actually saw people digging up the
reporter Erin Calvin's old tweets those
tweets made between 2010 and 2013 also
included racist and even homophobic
language also according to some reports
who repeatedly use the n-word and then
Calvin found himself apologizing for
those to beat you exactly what the [ __ ]
you were saying and who you gonna call
karma Buster's eyes rainin old tweets
Soulja Boy tell them not to use them
tweets isn't it crazy these guys came
out with that statement yes we think
that most reasonable adults can choose
what deserves and doesn't deserve to be
in an article okay the Internet's like
you've activated my trap card
yo yo your internet wins once again hold
back these cellphones yeah what did you
post when you were 15 I don't think you
should use your job [ __ ] them - tweets
brah brah
tweets and you stop saying tweets in a
sentence it sounds stupid
Ashley's a grown man saying tweets
bothers me tweets yeah I said a lot of
like tweets [ __ ] them - tweets he can't
even be mad and say it's like being mad
and say bubbles bubbles oh he got popped
up on his hood nice I spray some bubbles
at that [ __ ] yo tweets all over his
face
yeah and I can't take that [ __ ] serious
like like that's like I don't use
Twitter I just I think the whole needle
I just think my 12 sorry and get at you
tweet tweet
Tom oh well tell you about people in
glass houses do not be throwing them
rocks right and we all live in these
glass how I know when I was 16 I was
[ __ ] up I just didn't have Twitter
when he was 16 he was [ __ ] up we were
all so stop now quick little addition to
the story the reporter who exposed those
old tweets when Carson King was 16 was
fired by the Des Moines Register for the
tweets that were uncovered about him and
he said I did apologize for my tweets
and I regret them and I wouldn't publish
them now Calvin was 18 when he published
those racist tweets in an interview with
BuzzFeed news he said I would have never
said that word out loud at any point in
my life as I never had but he would
tweet about it publicly to the entire
world apparently and then and he
continues on saying Calvin I felt
abandoned by the newspaper because I
followed the standard editorial practice
by conducting the social media search on
Carson and that's what I had to do when
I wrote about him and this event is
basically set my life on fire and he
goes on to say obviously I've made
mistakes in my past everyone has and I
really hope people see this point in my
life I'm grown I'm caring I'm generous
and I hope that's what people focus on a
man also too but unfortunately people
like you make it so that we have to
focus on other things because that's
what you chose to publish right you say
you're all these good things why don't
you show that same courtesy to Carson
when you wrote about him in your
newspaper and that's the question we've
all been asking do you know how hard it
is to try to move past something
negative in your life and try to be a
better person and it's hard enough to
always try to wake up every day and to
choose to do good things for our
neighbors and here we have somebody who
wants to remind us of the negative
things that we've done in our life and
every turn when we try to do something
positive you want to be treated that way
well I would just hope that people when
they hear this story they just think to
themselves and they go I'm gonna treat
others how I would like to be treated so
while I do want to feel empathy for you
on an ethical standpoint I do karma
makes me want to say a Mitch you got
what you deserved
[Music]